we were talking about something that so
many people did you know the pandemic it
forced the closures and the quarantines
and what it did was push so many people
outside to explore more hiking more all
sorts of things there's a little bit of
everything here in southern nevada kate
houston is here to highlight a new
business trying to make the outdoors
more accessible hi kate
hi yes an adventure on a budget that's
the idea behind peaks and pedals gear
exchange the owner tells me there is a
robust outdoor community here in
southern nevada and by bringing down
financial barriers it could encourage
more people to get outside these items
can last a really long time so there's
no reason for us to throw them away
someone else can make use of them peeks
and petals gear exchange is an outdoor
consignment shop off of tanea and craig
in the northwest valley we are selling
outdoor used gear for hiking camping
climbing
snow sports and paddle sports owner
holly priest says outdoor gear is made
to last so reselling it is both
eco-conscious and budget-friendly i
understand that it costs a lot of money
to do the sports that we do
so being able to come in here and get
something at like a third of the price
is really important for moms like sonya
pedowick the consignment concept is
helpful for her growing kids each year
they grow a little bit so now we have to
take that into consideration what can be
passed down what cannot pedowick says it
also makes it easier to try new
activities because if it's not something
we want to fully invest in but want to
just try it this season and then maybe
sell it back or pass it on to someone
else that would be very interesting for
us priest hopes the shop will not only
outfit outdoor enthusiasts but cultivate
a recreational community in southern
nevada i love nevada i'm a nevada born
native and i think there's a lot of
potential
here for recreation and i built this to
support that
right now priest is looking for cycling
and winter gear and if people don't want
to sell they do take donations a portion
of that profit will go to various
outdoor nonprofits in our area